[Music]
poverty has forced more than 5.7 million
children across Latin America into child
labor and it's causing many of them to
drop out of school in major cities all
across the region these children often
end up working on the streets but the
streets can be dangerous and children
are left vulnerable to abuse alcohol
drugs and gangs in Peru more than 13,000
children are gang members but there's
one school in Lima offering kids an
alternative to street life through dance
and so far they've reached over a
hundred thousand children the d1 culture
Association was founded by former
ballerina
Vania Marcia's in 2005 la calle
operation pandyas porque necesita para
ponerse Araroa incentive / tenancy or
gente in relation to the whole system
this erosion amidst an intended in a
song so this a movie moment Arista this
on amiga journalism owes akima
fortunately no swimming faccio similar
una Pandya pero positive
Diego Ortega is a hip hop instructor and
dancer for the program he now teaches
and trains at their studio intro Rios an
upscale part of downtown Lima but his
journey with dance began on the streets
at 16 when he started performing
acrobatics at traffic stops the others
here it is enough for us for elder
Martin and Sierra I say paramita mayor
in a personal call Joe for another plot
economic imperative
Joakim be important to make a comedian
señor Garcia
until Sarah come okay get the me I think
is available Yaya team a player como que
quieran Pocoyo
today d1 is divided into two parts on
one side there's a dance schooling
company on the other a nonprofit
organization that offers free dance
workshops for at-risk youth but back in
2005 it all started with street
performers like Diego in the vehicle no
common psi they will know ii don't need
sinkhole yo and PSOE my photos
yo at needle a Chico no loving no female
nada should evoke a pandyas healings
here it's co-leader raffia todo lo que
su SE y en tu mente saline arraignment
are in sir yup render Graceffa gracias
para me I you know opportunity irony
Diego used the money he earned on the
streets to support himself and his
younger brother after they were
abandoned by their parents but he
quickly realized there was an
unsustainable lifestyle part of the
races a second CD was car are you gonna
call perk in la tercera crevasse es
bueno please comment on un poco dinero
para val largo plazo terminal matin
doctor in unity to work entonces por el
tema cuidado edik we dharma me means
water in the sea on mr. gendell cm very
that's when he decided to join the d1
dance program that had recently opened
up a studio in his hometown but I could
take Menden McKeehan drop a check UT es
como que ver qué saben que una LaValle
Imam al otro que que sera is a is a pro
you andreas mister
Mauricio in Greenlee Indiana Sarah come
okay artyom horrible original Kingdom at
home up Arizona King way de cambiar
Moscow says he eventually joined D ones
professional dance company and went on
to win competitions across the country
computer personnel mean they cased esta
cosa que mi caballo como el seguro
spittle in Navi are gross areas in estar
el apoyo are in estar con la otra
persona finale necesitas in mahira a
toda part l Aransas co would you put in
fluency mi familia come up you can be re
so today he regularly teaches free
outreach workshops at the same studio
where he got his start
yeah he almost areas around yo timing in
Ishika yo también fue no stays until
mañana por que si yo me siento como your
numbers are sobre como se us to proceed
upon a llegar ax
a stature Rios austere kini somos saga
normal su nombre vamos a compartir no
casi lo mismo pero si con similarities
the goal of the workshops is to provide
students with an alternative to street
gangs featuring role models from their
own communities the funciona para
nosotros is siempre raha calm profesores
de la misma to muneerah inclusive police
are you a ho
único successful Shanna tanto que si -
Lacey stay and non SI ella poiseuille
for k2 and immediacy no like Diego
students who attend the workshops have
the opportunity to audition for the t1
dance company my side yeah a while as me
gusto laughs Foreman como yo guruma me
you Garen de la mejor manera nylon dur
être Videla palabras de como Teresa
naked
esto es una impulsive para salir 'as i
said okay to empress career
but the focus isn't just teaching dance
the d1 program wants to empower students
and give them an artistic outlet say lo
que somos en otro no for Mama faillerina
from au pair of sona-nyl of ramos listo
para aumentar say al mundo yeah lo que
yo quiero que le hameau son a ceremony
and doesn't know the your sister
blessing locating a quarter-million
arigato placer the citizenry horses
Skinner is a moving this is K know what
that is creator sustainer principal
iratus company refuses to nip well we
are no porque si que demo while arena
say muchos Jeff Wayne's paranoia a I
compared location the wind Borisovich
waiting up for Karma's
[Applause]
[Music]